si se le ha diagnosticado diabetes tipo
1 o tipo 2 puede usar una bomba de
insulina para controlar el nivel de
glucosa en su sangre una bomba de
insulina es un dispositivo que funciona
con baterías utilizado para administrar
insulina de acción rápida al cuerpo
mediante un catéter sustituyendo la
necesidad de aplicarse inyecciones
periódicamente las partes del
dispositivo incluyen una bomba que
funciona con baterías un depósito
descartable de insulina y un chip de
computadora programado para administrar
las dosis precisas para ayudar a
mantener un nivel de glucosa uniforme
puede programar la bomba con
anticipación para que administre
insulina de manera continua las 24 horas
del día una bomba de insulina puede
ayudarle a ajustar el nivel de azúcar en
su sangre de inmediato también puede
programar la bomba para administrar
dosis émbolo más grandes de insulina
justo antes de comer para que regularice
o cubra la cantidad de carbohidratos que
va a consumir una vez que ha determinado
su nivel de glucosa con la ayuda de un
glucómetro puede programar su bomba para
enviar la cantidad correcta de insulina
a su cuerpo la insulina viaja desde la
bomba a través de un conjunto de info
y que incluye un tubo flexible adjunto a
una cánula de plástico suave que se
inserta justo debajo de la piel usar una
bomba de insulina puede ayudarle a tener
un estilo de vida más flexible y a la
vez le ayuda a mantener un nivel de
glucosa estable todo el tiempo los
estudios muestran que el control y
mantenimiento regular de los niveles de
glucosa ayudan a evitar complicaciones a
largo plazo relacionadas con la diabetes
tal como ceguera enfermedades renales
enfermedades cardíacas y accidentes
cardiovasculares